>> REPUBLICACONGRESSMAN GLENN
THOMPSON ATTENDED HIS GAY SON'S
WEDDING LAST WEEK, AND UNDER
ANY OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD
NOT BE NEWS, JUST A HAPPY DAY
FOR A CONGRESSMAN AND HIS
FAMILY.
BUT GET THIS, ONLY THREE DAYS
BEFORE THE WEDDING, THOMPSON
VOTED AGAINST A BILL TO PROTECT
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
HE IS ONE OF THE REPUBLICANS
WHO VOTED TO OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD CODIFY
SAME-SEX MARRIAGES, AND VOTED
INTO.
LAW THAT THE VOTE NEEDS TEN GOP
VOTES TO PASS.
SCOTT JENNINGS AND EDINBURGH
ARE BOTH HERE TO DISCUSS THIS.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH --
GOOD EVENING.
CAUGHT-IFYING MARRIAGE AND,
WHATEVER.
ANNA, LISTEN TO THIS.
THOMPSON'S OFFICE SAID THAT THE
CONGRESSMAN AND HIS WIFE WERE
THRILLED TO ATTEND THEIR SONS
NUPTIALS AND THEY ARE VERY
HAPPY TO WELCOME A NEW CNN LAW
IN THE FAMILY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, WE CAN ASK WHY
HE VOTED AGAINST THE BILL.
WHY DOES THAT MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
>> FIRST OF, ALL LET ME TELL,
YOU CONGRESSMAN THOMPSON SUN,
AND THEN YOU SON-IN-LAW, ARE
THE TWO MOST FORGIVING,
GRACIOUS NICEST GAYS I HAVE
EVER MET.
BECAUSE, MY FATHER HAD VOTED
AGAINST PROTECTING AND
SAFEGUARDING THE SANCTITY OF MY
MARRIAGE THREE DAYS BEFORE MY
WEDDING, IF I HAD BEEN HIS SON,
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT WOULD'VE BEEN
SITTING OUTSIDE ON THE CHAIR,
ON THE HOTTEST OF THE YEAR.
AND SEE HOW THAT GOES.
IT'S PAINFUL, AND I CAN'T
BELIEVE PEOPLE WHO PUT --
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE PEOPLE WHO
PUT POLITICS OVER COUNTRY.
IT'S EVEN HARDER TO UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE WHO PUT POLITICAL AND
POLITICS OVER.
FAMILY AND LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT TWO REPUBLICANS WHO DID.
IT ONE OF THUMB IS MY FRIEND
CONGRESSWOMAN ILYA NO ROSSLYN,
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN, WHO
BECAME A LEADER ON THIS ISSUE.
AND ANOTHER ONE IS SENATOR ROB
PORTMAN WHO HAS A GAY SON
WILLIAM, AND WHO IS THE
REPUBLICAN WHO SIGNED UP TO
COSPONSOR THIS BILL IN THE
SENATE.
SO, YOU KNOW, POLITICS SHOULD
NOT BE THICKER THAN BLOOD.
>> LISTEN, I DO HAVE TO SAY
THAT WE ASKED CONGRESSMAN
THOMPSON TO JOIN US ON THIS
VERY PROGRAM, WE HAVEN'T HEARD,
BECKY IS WELCOME, BECAUSE
ACTION WANT TO HEAR WHAT HE
SAYS, AND I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
HIS SON AND THE NEW HUSBAND ON.
BUT WHY DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS,
SCOTT?
>> I DON'T KNOW CONGRESSMAN
THOMPSON WOULDN'T PRETEND TO
KNOW WHAT A RELATIONSHIP IS
BETWEEN HIM AND HIS SON.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY PERSONAL.
I DID READ HIS OFFICES
STATEMENT, AND HIS OFFICE SAID
HE WAS VOTING NO BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT IT WAS A SHOW VOTE, AND
IT WAS A DISTRACTION FROM THE
REAL ISSUES OF THE DAY.
SO I HAVE TAKEN HIM AND HIS
OFFICE ON THEIR WORD ON THAT.
THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL DEAL
BETWEEN HIM AND HIS SON.
I WON'T EVEN PRETEND TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BETWEEN THEM,
AND I AM GLAD HE WENT.
I KNOW SOME PEOPLE WHO'VE HAD
SIMILAR SITUATIONS IN THEIR
FAMILY WHERE THE PARENTS CHOSE
NOT TO ATTEND, AND CHOSE NOT TO
ENGAGE, WHICH I THINK IS
INCREDIBLY SAD, TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU, WHEN PEOPLE CANNOT
STEP LIBERATE THEIR FAMILY.
SO IT'S A STRANGE SITUATION,
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE FROM HIS
OFFICE A STATEMENT, DON, THEY
WANT TO KEEP THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN HIM AND HIS SON MORE
PRIVATE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER
BUSINESS OF THE DAY BUT THIS IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT ONE.
I THINK MARRIAGE BETWEEN TWO
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF RACE
OR SEX --
THAT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT.
MARCO RUBIO LAST WEEK TOLD CNN
THAT THE BILL WAS A STUPID
WASTE OF TIME HAD THIS TO SAY
AFTER CRITICISM FROM PEOPLE BUT
A JUDGE, WHO IS GAY, AND IN
RELATIONSHIP WITH A SAME-SEX
PARTNER --
>> I'M NOT GONNA FOCUS ON THE
AGENDA DICTATED BY ELITE
LIBERALS AND MARXIST MISFITS
WHO, SADLY, TODAY CONTROL THE
AGENDA OF MODERN DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> THIS IS, SCOTT, A REAL
PROBLEM WHO CAN'T STAND TO LOSE
RIGHTS.
DO YOU THINK YOUR PARTIES ON
THE WRONG SIDE OF THIS ISSUE?
>> WELL, I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THE POLLING ON GAY MARRIAGE,
SPECIFICALLY, IT'S MOVED ALONG,
LONG WAY FROM JUST TEN YEARS
AGO, 15 YEARS AGO.
EVEN REALLY FIVE YEARS AGO.
I THINK A MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS KNOW SUPPORTED A
PRETTY WIDE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS NOW SUPPORT IT.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ACTING DIFFERENT WAYS
FOR JURISDICTIONAL REASONS.
PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT MORE RURAL
STATES WHO AREN'T CHURCHGOERS
WILL FEEL ONE WAY, AND PEOPLE
WHO WILL REPRESENT OTHER
CONSTITUENCIES WILL FEEL
ANOTHER.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE A SPIT
CONFERENCE JUST AS YOU SAW ON
THE HOUSE.
MY PRESUMPTION IS, DON, IT'S
GONNA PASS IN THE SENATE.
IT WILL GET AT LEAST TEN
REPUBLICAN VOTES.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ALL ARE
YET, BUT MY PRESUMPTION IS THAT
IT'S GOING TO GET THERE.
WHICH WOULD'VE BEEN UNTHINKABLE
TEN YEARS AGO.
SO I THINK THE REPUBLICANS WILL
MOVE SOMEWHAT ON THIS, JUST AT
THE SAME TIME, POPULAR OPINION
HAS MOVED AS WELL.
>> AND YOU SAID RURAL, I GREW
UP IN A RURAL AREA, THEY NEEDED
THE MOST.
THERE ARE MORE GAYS IN THE
RURAL AREAS THEN YOU CAN SHAKE
A STICK OUT.
BUT NO ONE CAME OUT, AND THAT
WAS VERY DETRIMENTAL TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
THAT PEOPLE DID NOT COME OUT,
THEY COULDN'T LIVE AND BE
THEMSELVES AND TO THIS DAY,
THEY ARE SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
COME OUT.
OR MAYBE LATER IN LIFE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT MESSES
WITH THEIR HEAD AND THE END UP
DOING BAD THINGS, IT'S A RIPPLE
EFFECT.
BUT WHEN YOU TALK OF PEOPLE WHO
CHANGE.
LIZ CHENEY CHANGED, SHE
SUPPORTED THAT HOUSE BILL, SHE
IS SOMEONE WHO CHANGED HER
VIEWS BECAUSE HER GAY SISTER,
RIGHT?
>> I THINK IT'S HARD RACIST, OR
YES.
I THINK KNOWING SOMEONE WHO IS
GAY, I THINK KNOWING SOMEONE
WHO IS GAY IN A COMMITTED
RELATIONSHIP CHANGES YOU
BECAUSE YOU ARE SEEING IT.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
REPUBLICANS CAN CALL THEMSELVES
THE PARTY OF FAMILY VALUES AND
VOTE AGAINST SAFEGUARDING
MARRIAGE.
>> WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY, HERE IS
WHETHER THIS CHENEY SAID ON
CNN.
SHE SUPPORTING THE BILL SAYING,
FREEDOM MEANS FREEDOM FOR
EVERYBODY.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
BASIS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
FREEDOM FOR EVERYONE.
>> AND DON, WELL IT'S NOT JUST
THIS CHENEY WHO CHANGED.
BROCK OBAMA ALSO CHANGE ON.
THAT'S WHEN I FIRST MET HIM IN
2008, HE WAS NOT PRO MARRIAGE
EQUALITY.
TODAY, HE IS.
SO THE ENTIRE COUNTRY HAS
CHANGED OVER 71% OF AMERICANS
NOW SUPPORT GAY MARRIAGE.
AND THIS BILL IT WAS NOT JUST
ABOUT GAY MARRIAGE, THIS BILL
WAS ABOUT INTEGRATION MARRIAGE,
INTER ETHNIC MARRIAGE, MARRIAGE
BETWEEN DIFFERENT
NATIONALITIES.
IT IS PROTECTING THE
INSTITUTION OF MARRIAGE WHICH
REPUBLICANS HANG THEIR HEAD ON
SO MUCH.
AND I CAN THINK OF SO MANY GAY
FRIENDS OF MINE, FLORIDIANS,
WHO ARE MERIT, AND SOME OF THEM
HAVE GAY CHILDREN WHO ARE
MARRIED, WHO ARE MARKETABLE
DONORS.
AND I'M GONNA BE CALLING THOSE
PEOPLE, AND GONNA BE TELLING,
THEM YOU KNOW WHAT'S?
YOU SHOULD TELL MERKEL REVEAL
THAT GIVING HIM MONEY AND
SUPPORTING HIM IS A ROYALS,
STUPID WASTE OF TIME.
>> SO ONLY GAY LEFTIST'S, ONLY
LEAD LEFTIST ARE GAY?
>> LISTEN, MARCO RUBIO TODAY,
EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
HIS MOUTH IS A NOUN, A VERB,
AND SOCIALIST MARCUS LENINIST.
>> I'VE GOTTA GO, SCOTT.
BUT LISTEN, WE WILL CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION.
BUT THANK YOU.
ALL I CAN TELL YOU ONE THANK,
YOU TALKED ABOUT BARACK OBAMA.
I WENT TO A WHITE HOUSE
CHRISTMAS PARTY WITH ORACLE
BOMBER WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
AND WENT AFTER IT CAME OUT, HE
SAID, YOU KNOW YOU GO TO LUNCH,
AND HE SAID TO ME, HE AND THE
FIRST LADY SAID, DON, YOU DID
THE RIGHT THING.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONLY THING
I REMEMBER.
HE SAID A LOT TO, ME I REMEMBER
WHEN HE WAS A STATE SENATOR IN
CHICAGO.
I USED TO COVER, HIM BUT THAT
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME.
HE SAID --
>> HE WAS NOT PRO GAME MARRIAGE
WHEN HE WAS.
RUNNING >> YEAH.